Shia LaBeouf has been arrested again  King Ichi can confirm the 31 year old  actor was taken into custody in Savannah  Georgia early Saturday morning a  spokesperson for the Chatham County  Sheriff's Office tells et Shia was  booked with public drunkenness  disorderly conduct and obstruction he  was released from the Chatham County  Detention Center where he was being held  on a thirty-five hundred dollar bond  Shia is currently in Savannah shooting  his new film the peanut butter Falcon  this isn't the transformer star's first  brush with the law earlier this year he  was arrested while protesting president  donald trump and was charged with  misdemeanor assault and harassment he  has reached out to shy as rep for  comment  you